-Try the chicken.
It's the greatest.
-Uh, it looks spicy.
My stomach.
-Oh, you're missing out, Marty.
But then again, I suspect you
miss out on a lot, don't you?
Do you think the goal in life
is to avoid getting hurt?
The goal of life is to live.
Getting hurt is just the price
of admission, my friend.
-We're back with Paul Rudd,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, this is
"The Shrink Next Door."
This is based on a true story.
-Yeah.
-And it's you and Will Ferrell.
You guys haven't worked together
since "Anchorman."
And this is a giant departure.
Which is good,
because it would be very weird
to do something else
in the same tone as "Anchorman."
-Yeah.
As fun as that was.
Yeah, this is a different thing.
This is a true story.
It was based on --
There was a podcast called
"The Shrink Next Door"
that came out
a couple years ago
that follows the story of these,
kind of, really, these two guys,
a therapist and his patient.
Will plays the patient,
Marty Markowitz.
And it kind of tracks them over
the course of about 30 years,
and it's -- he didn't pick
the right therapist.
[ Laughter ]
-That becomes apparent
very clear --
very early
in their relationship.
-Right. Yeah.
So -- But then, over time,
you know, he kind of --
You know, you kind of
get sucked in a little bit,
and the therapist kind of
takes over his life
a little bit, yeah.
-Was it nice
to work with Will again?
Obviously, it's been some years.
-The greatest.
-Yeah.
-You know him really well.
Who's better than that guy?
-Yeah, it's really true.
And I don't mean to blow smoke.
But you guys are very similar
in that when people ask me
what people like you are like,
I'm like, "You can't believe it,
but they're as nice
as you would want them to be."
-Well, you're very nice
for saying that.
I'm kind of --
I'm pretty awed by the guy.
And I just think
that it is true.
He treats people
really, really well.
And he's so
kind of sweet and talented.
I loved working with him
on this, too,
because it's such
a different side of him,
but you really get to see, like,
"Oh, yeah, he's a great actor
in addition
to being a great guy."
So, it was really --
it was a real blast
to work on it with him on it.
-You're also in the new
"Ghostbusters" film.
Congratulations.
We were talking about stage.
I had such
an emotional reaction to it,
not just based on how great
the film is, but, like,
seeing "Ghostbusters" as a kid,
I have a real memory of, like,
going to the theater
and seeing that film
and feeling like,
"Oh, this is a kids movie,
but the people in it are cooler
than most people
in kids movies."
-Right.
[ Light laughter ]
-Which must have made it
so amazing to be asked
to be a part
of the legacy of it.
-Yeah, for sure.
I mean that was --
Our generation,
I mean, I remember, too,
when that movie came out,
and it was an event.
And then, it becomes kind of
part of just the culture,
that Ray Parker Jr. song,
and everything was,
from all angles,
it was just a huge deal.
And so now, this is made in --
Jason Reitman wrote it
and directed it.
His father, Ivan Reitman,
directed the original.
So, there's this
just lineage that's happening,
and to kind of be a part
of all that is pretty nuts.
-And, you know, trying not
to give anything away,
but we had the original --
the three Ghostbusters
who are still with us --
Bill and Danny and Ernie.
And it just must have been so
surreal to see them showing up
on set and getting to
not just work them
but see them
in their old bustin' gear.
[ Laughter ]
-It's pretty surreal.
[ Laughs ]
Pretty surreal to say the least,
for sure, yeah.
-I feel like you --
Every time you're here,
there's things
that you're worried --
that you don't want
to give away spoilers.
Like, that's one of
the terrifying things
of being an actor
in the Marvel Universe.
-Well, it's like
a weird thing now, isn't it?
That we're, you know,
all of a sudden,
there are all these things
you can't talk about
and things that, yeah,
you don't want to give away.
I think --
-Yeah, it must be
especially hard when you go on,
like, a talk show.
[ Laughter ]
-Knowing it's gonna be an issue.
Yeah.
It's a minefield.
-So, you were here, and we were
talking about the things
you can't talk about.
-Mm.
This is before
they had announced
the title of the Marvel film was
"Avengers: Endgame."
-Mm.
-That was a big announcement.
-Right.
-Which I will say,
I think that's really silly,
because I feel like people
are gonna see those movies,
no matter what the titles are.
[ Laughter ]
-I think you're right.
-I think I'm right.
-I think that one had
a good shot of -- yeah.
-Yeah, I mean,
I feel like even it's called
"Avengers:
The Gang's Back Together,"
I think people would've like...
[ Laughter ]
I did not know
the title was "Endgame."
-Right, no one did.
It wasn't announced.
-But then, we were having
a conversation here,
and I said, "Endgame."
And I want to show the clip,
because I feel like,
in that moment,
you looked like you're worried
that you accidentally told me.
-"Did I mess up?"
-Yeah.
-Oh.
-Show it real quick.
-I think I messed up.
I think I messed up.
-You think you messed up.
-Yeah.
-Well, I think...
[ Audience groans, applause ]
I don't know how
that could mess up, though,
'cause I would only think
that would make
more people see the movie,
which I feel like's the endgame.
-You know what? You're right.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, there's a pause.
-Yeah!
-Oh, my God!
I think my stomach went, "Ugh!"
[ Laughter ]
-You go back
to the dressing room,
they're like,
"We have a new Ant-Man."
[ Laughter ]
"We're using our backup
Ant-Man from here on out."
-"We're gonna
go with Will Ferrell."
-"We hear
he's lovely to work with, Paul."
-"He's the greatest guy
in show business."
-Hey, thanks
for being here again, man.
It's always such a pleasure
to see you.
Paul Rudd, everybody.
New episodes of
"The Shrink Next Door"
available to stream
Fridays on Apple TV+.